please welcome the lovely sydney sweetie
oh you're so lovely thanks you look
amazing it is an honor and a privilege
to meet you in person and you're such an
extraordinary actress
and um
you know i was curious
with something like white lotus do you
take the script
and have an arc
of where you start and where you go
because you did such a
extraordinary 180 but in interesting
degrees and measurements
with white lotus was actually a
different approach than i've ever done
before okay because i was really nervous
to do comedy and i've never really done
comedy before
and i i really wanted to work with mike
because mike wise just incredible he's a
genius genius and everything from molly
i was working with the most incredible
comedians yeah like molly shannon's
incredible
coolidge is incredible like connie
britton it was just
an amazing comedy workshop and i finally
just put everything aside i was like i'm
just gonna soak up everything i can
learn possible and take in the moment
and kind of just
bring it to life as it went well it
worked thank you um okay so what was
your approach
for euphoria that's a very different
tone it's a very different type very
different it's definitely a darker tone
i was not a as rebellious as cassie was
but you know it's kind of fun i'm
getting to live out those like teenage
experiences i never really experienced
before
like you're a good girl i i would never
do what she did on a carousel
[Laughter]
like what
in fact
you are such a good girl like when you
watched euphoria with your dad
well no see the problem was i completely
forgot to tell my dad i was doing
euphoria and um he sat down with my
grandparents and turned on euphoria and
how long did that last five minutes
yeah
and what did you say to him i got the
phone call what is this
what do you mean what is this because
euphoria go oh my god i completely
forgot to tell him
that's not the show you just sit down
with nana
you have all this incredible stuff that
you're doing but there's something else
that you put on your extraordinarily
busy plate will you tell people about
what it is i was trying to balance
college and
acting at the same time and i was
working it to get a business degree
and i was filming a handmaid's tale and
i was trying to take all these classes
at the same time and my finals came
along and i was in toronto and everyone
over at hulu was so kind and they let me
go back for my finals and i went back
and i i walk into
my entertainment law class
and my professor goes what are you doing
here
what do you mean i'm here to take my
final he goes no you're not i'm like
what are you talking about and
apparently all the kids were upset that
i was able to miss so many days of
school
and still succeed even though i made
dean's list every semester for two years
and
he didn't let me take the final and i
never got credit
i know
so the overachiever
i struggled really hard with that one
that's that's a tough pill to swallow i
was valedictorian in high school like i
loved school
like a lot it was hard
kids didn't understand professors don't
understand it's hard i get i mean i
understand but then at the same time
it's like i was working really hard well
i think this wrong will be righted and
i cannot wait to hear the end of this
story thank you maybe i'll go to law
school
you recently bought your first house yes
i did and you're a fan of design i um
okay so i saw the property brothers once
and i freaked out so much i was too
nervous to go say hi
and this is during handmaid's sale and
so i finally i was like okay you got
this you can go up to them just say hi
you're a big fan i mean i love them
and i go up and they love me from
handmaid's tale and then they follow me
on instagram and then we dm and i freak
out like every time i see a notification
design really is such a huge part of my
life and you've been doing your own
wallpapers like putting it up yourself
i so the house i bought is from 1933.
everything is original
like you can tell that when you walk in
the walls are just filled with memories
and i want to like honor those memories
but then be able to bring in my own as
well
so i'm like wallpapering every wall
because i'm like i don't have to take it
down and i've been ordering wallpaper
off of etsy and just putting it up
myself so i turned my entire entire
dining room into like a floral
forest it's amazing maybe one day we
could collaborate and design something
i love that i love that
you also restore old cars i do where
does it end with you sydney sweeney i
could never decide to be one thing
i mean you're so cool
you're like under the hood yes you're
underneath the car you're what
what what
how
well i always wanted to and then
i was i never was able to i never had
the means to be able to do it and
finally dreams came true
and i
bought a 1969 bronco off an auction site
it's all original and
i decided to just fix it up myself i
changed out the axles i changed the drum
brakes disc brakes i changed the entire
transmission
i mean i knew that i loved you and now i
know i'm in love
[Applause]
[Music]